I make an average of about $200 a week
working full-time
and my new job is to stay alive using my
new job is to stay alive that was from a
worried instacart shopper as employees
at online delivery companies are now
concerned about their personal safety
amid this pandemic staging walk outs
sick outs as you just heard and strikes
to leverage management for higher pay
and better health protections a and B
puzzler is a senior fellow at the
Pepperdine University School of Public
Policy he's also the former CEO at cke
restaurants the parent company as you
would know a Hardee's and Carl's jr. and
others and he is the author of the book
the capitalists comeback Andy puzzle
joins us now 80 good morning thanks for
being here hey Sandra good to be here
thank you
so you're a really important voice in
this conversation because you used to
run that company that that oversaw all
of those restaurant chains you had
worker issues all the time some are
calling these instacart shoppers Amazon
the Packers heroes because they've been
they've continued to work in this
environment those instacart shoppers
play a key role in helping some of those
most vulnerable shop in the grocery
store and then leave it in their
doorstep are the companies doing enough
to protect them well I think the
companies are doing what they can look
at these people at Amazon and mystic art
they these aren't stupid people I mean
they know that the two most important
things in a business are number one your
employees and number two your customers
so I'm sure they want to do everything
they can one to protect the employees
health but if they're not protecting
their employees if they're allowing this
virus to spread and their facilities
they're going to lose business people
are going to stop ordering from them so
I I'm sure they'll do everything they
possibly can now they may not do what
Alexandria or Acacio of Cortez wants
them to do because I think she would
prefer that employees just get paid and
stayed home 365 days a year which is of
course impossible but I think I think
these companies will do everything they
can I don't know if they're doing enough
now they should be very concerned
about these demonstrations because
they're you know if people if people get
afraid to order online they're gonna
stop ordering online and that would be a
disaster for the country right now with
the current crisis it's a it's an
extremely valuable surface service that
those individuals and their companies
are offering in the case of this Amazon
worker at the facility in Staten Island
there has been a back-and-forth trying
to reveal what exactly happened there
because why would that employee be fired
in the middle of all of this the fired
worker put out a statement and said this
Andy Amazon would rather fire workers
than face up to its total failure to do
what it should to keep us our families
and our communities safe I'm outraged
and disappointed but I'm not shocked as
usual Amazon we'd rather sweep a problem
under the rug then act to keep workers
and working communities safe
Amazon responded with its own statement
saying that despite that instruction to
stay home with pay
he came on site today March 30th further
putting the teams at risk
this is unacceptable and we have
terminated his employment as a result of
these multiple safety issues you know if
you were to take this bigger picture
Andy this is an example of so much of
the concern problems coordination that
these companies face with their
employees to keep them safe but also to
keep them working well you know you know
because you're an activist that doesn't
insulate you from abiding by the company
safety procedures and if in fact he
violated those procedures then they
weren't fully within their rights to
fire him and they should have fired him
because he's in there doing exactly what
he's protesting against he would have
been spreading the virus now I don't I
don't know if he's done that we don't
know what happened we got two versions
here but I haven't heard him deny it in
any of the statements that were issued
and therefore I think it was not
probably acted correctly but that
doesn't mean you should go find
employees every time they speak up
either and them needs to solve this yeah
it is quite a back and forth that's
happening I just want to finish with the
New York Attorney General statement that
did get in there Letitia James saying
New York the right to organize is
codified into law at a time when so many
New Yorkers are struggling she says and
are deeply concerned about their safety
this action was also immoral and
inhumane the office of the AG's is
considering all legal options so I think
that's a story we're gonna watch for
some time but Andy final thoughts you
wrote about the big capitalists comeback
what happens what happens after we get
through the worst of this on the medical
side and saving lives and then and then
we see the administration try to open
the economy back up how much can we come
back and how fast can that happen well
we could come back very quickly if Trump
does what he did during in the first
three years of his administration and
steps back and encourages businesses to
hire lowering taxes reducing regulation
I hope that we don't make the mistake
that we made at the end of the the Great
Recession with the Obama administration
where they came in with the stimulus and
the Affordable Care Act and the
dodd-frank act attempting to you know to
take advantage of a crisis to enact some
you know some socialist collectivist
agenda we need to make sure that
American businesses are free to grow
that they have the ability to grow that
the government isn't suppressing that
growth and will come back very quickly
so I think Trump spirt last three years
the first three years of this
administration were a perfect roadmap
for what we need to do in this crisis is
over and Obama's eight years are a
perfect roadmap for what we shouldn't do
when this crisis is over so I think we
can come back quickly well there has
been bipartisan support for at least
that stimulus for now to get out to
those struggling American family we need
it now we need it now we don't need it
when this isn't when it's over it's over
we need it now to get through this
there's nobody's arguing about that and
epubs are great to have you on this
morning thank you
thanks Sandra